we're in North Carolina where strange
objects are being engulfed by a moldable
magnetic monster
this is like some kind of weird alien
goo from out of space it is creepy
it may be out-of-this-world weird but
this isn't from another planet it's
magnetic putty eerily demonstrated by
Joe shaken Berg aka Joey shanks my
favorite part of this clip is when the
blob needs a disco ball it's like the
death of disco all over again
we met Joey in his homemade laboratory
to find out more about this strange
attraction I've done everything from
making dries bubbles to making petri
dish planets in creating galaxies with
food coloring and milk and I also have
made really interesting reactions using
magnetic putty to create this
magnificent display of magnets Joey uses
time lapse taking one picture every
second that one probably took ten
minutes for it to fully be engulfed and
it pretty much looks like he's just
gonna going like that and it worked out
pretty good and told you to put some
sound effects of him like screaming or
something how does this peculiar putty
do this Joey has made a video using a
very strong magnet called neodymium like
this one and also magnetic putty like
this and when you put them together the
magic happens the key to the pussy's
really creepy behavior is that it
contains loads of particles of iron
oxide or magnetite
each speck of iron oxide contains many
negatively charged electrons now each
electron has its own magnetic field
which means they're like tiny bar
magnets in general they're arranged at
random so there's no overall magnetic
field as you bring a powerful magnet
close to the party
all these randomly aligned tiny bar
magnets start to align itself with a
magnetic field of the magnet and this
causes the putty to start moving
forwards and start enveloping the
magnets
I played with magnetic putty for hours
on end I've thought of every different
concept I could think of I'm putting
glitter on different sparkles hitting it
with different lights so I've become
quite fond of a magnet putty and I've
become quite close to it
I think I understand it better than
anyone else on the planet and I don't
think there's anything I can't do with
it but still I know that there are more
possibilities out there this is so cool
it's like alien I
[Music]